Olá pessoal hoje eu vou falar sobre os
sinais e sintomas da falta de
aminoácidos essenciais eles são
componentes super importantes pra nossa
vida eles são sem exagero os principais
blocos de construção de tudo que nós
somos então podemos imaginar os
aminoácidos como tijolos e as proteínas
como se fosse uma parede formada por
eles eles atuam em praticamente todas as
funções vitais desde a regenera de nossa
pele e cabelo até o funcionamento
aprimorado de nossos órgãos glândulas e
até mesmo nossas artérias são essenciais
para cura de feridas transmissão de
sinais no cérebro construção muscular e
muito mais incluindo a regulação do
sistema cardiovascular e sistema
imunitário pessoal existe um Desafio o
nosso corpo ele não consegue fazer todos
os aminoácidos de que precisamos são
nove aminoácidos essenciais que a gente
tem que buscar na nossa alimentação ou
às vezes através de suplementos E se a
gente não tem o suficiente deles o corpo
começa a dar sinais como se estivesse
tentando dizer algo pode ser um cansaço
não tem explicação dificuldade para
dormir ou até aquela dor no músculo que
a gente não sabe de onde veio então
Vamos aos nove aminoácidos essenciais e
os seus sintomas o primeiro a istidina
esse aminoácidos é um dos pilares
essenciais da Saúde atuando não só no
crescimento e reparo dos nossos tecidos
mas também protegendo nossas células
incluindo as células nervosas Imaginem a
istidina ajuda na formação de carnosina
uma substância importante que
encontramos no nossos músculos e no
cérebro Além disso ela é uma precursora
da estamina que é um neurotransmissor
que tem um papel Vital nas células do
sistema de defesa imune a istidina
também ajuda a manter o equilíbrio de
minerais importantes como zinco e ferro
Transportando o zinco até as células que
precisam mas pessoal a deficiência de
istidina Pode mostrar sinais como
irritação na pele ou até mesmo erupções
cutâneas sintomas de alergias ou rinite
outros sintomas como anemia pressão
arterial baixa problemas com Artrite e
dores nas circulações além de fadiga e
cansaço também podem ser ados pela falta
desse aminoácido tão essencial o segundo
aminoácido que nós vamos falar hoje é
isoleucina é super importante na
regulação do açúcar do sangue na
produção de energia na nossa recuperação
muscular pós exercícios e na produção de
hemoglobina no sangue quando falamos de
recuperação muscular e energia a
isoleucina está lá ela está firme forte
ao lado da leucina e da valina formando
um trio poderoso junto elas são
precursoras da glutamina e da lanina
dois aminoácidos que cumprem a função de
fornecer energia durante exercícios de
intensa atividade muscular Mas amigos é
importante Estar atento aos sinais do
corpo pois a falta de isoleucina pode
nos deixar numa situação bem complicada
Imaginem só tontura dor de cabeça aquela
confusão mental que parece que não vamos
conseguir clarear as ideias
irritabilidade FAD insônia tremores
musculares e até fadiga muscular já a
leucina é um dos três aminoácidos de
cadeia ramificada os bcas que é um grupo
importante pra saúde muscular a leucina
desempenha papéis fundamentais do corpo
incluindo a síntese de proteínas a
reparação de tecidos a regulação dos
níveis de açúcar no sangue e até a
produção de hormônios como é o caso do
hormônio crescimento sabiam que durante
a velice aumentar a ingestão de leucina
pode ajudar a reduzir a perda de massa
muscular por isso a leucina é essencial
em todas as fases da vida mas cuidado a
falta de leucina pode trazer uma série
de problemas você pode enfrentar
sintomas de hipoglicemia que é a baixa
concentração de glicose no sangue Você
pode ter dificuldade em ganhar massa
muscular até ter perda de cabelo e PR as
crianças a deficiência de leucina pode
impactar de forma negativa o crescimento
e agora eu quero falar sobre um
aminoácido super especial que já ganhou
até um vídeo exclusivo aqui no canal e
por acaso não esqueçam de conferir na
descrição eu estou falando da lisina a
lisina é fundamental especialmente no
que se refere ao crescimento e reparo do
tecido muscular e na produção de
hormônios e enzimas são peças chave pro
nosso metabolismo funcionar de forma
adequada de forma direita mas para mim
um dos grandes destaques da lisina é no
suporte ao sistema de defesa sistema
imune Especialmente na produção de
anticorpos que neutralizam invasores
como vírus e bactérias sem lisina de
forma suficiente Podemos enfrentar Uma
verdadeira batalha para produzir esses
defensores o que deixa nosso corpo mais
vulnerável a infecções e doenças a falta
de lisina pessoal pode trazer um monte
de problemas desde falta de apetite e
náuseas até fadiga extrema até mesmo
insônia problemas de dificuldade
reprodutiva crescimento atrofiado em
crianças e tem mais essa deficiência
pode causar perda de cabelo dificuldade
de concentração perda de memória
irritabilidade ansiedade também
enfraquecer nossa imunidade não deixar
mais sujeitos a infecções frequentes
Vamos falar agora da metionina esse
aminoácido essencial é um grande aliado
do nosso metab ismo e num processo de
detox
desintoxicação ajudando a eliminar
substâncias nocivas no nosso corpo ela é
essencial na formação de proteínas e na
conversão em moléculas importantes que
conté enxofre que protege nossos tecidos
ajudam na modificação do DNA e mantém as
células funcionando a todo o vapor e não
é só isso a metionina também é uma Peça
chave para manter nosso fígado
saudável o acúmulo de gordura falando em
antioxidantes a metionina tem um papel
na prevenção do envelhecimento precoce
graças a sua habilidade em contribuir na
formação da cisteína que por sua vez é
responsável pela produção de glutationa
que é o principal antioxidante um
potente antioxidante que combate os
radicais livres e também participa
ativamente no detox Além disso pessoal a
metionina é um verdadeiro reforço pra
saúde da pele cabelo e unhas trazendo
mais Tom flexibilidade e fortalecimento
e ela ainda tem um papel importante na
proteção das células contra poluentes e
sendo crucial paraa absorção de celen e
Zinco agora uma coisa é certa a falta de
metionina não é brincadeira e pode
trazer problemas sérios pra saúde desde
o inchaço por retenção de líquidos o
famoso edema até dificuldades na
cicatrização de feridas cabelos e unhas
e pode também ficar com unhas fracas e
comprometer a função do fígado levando a
condições mais graves como a esteatose
ou gordura do fígado já o aminoá fenil
alanina é bem menos conhecido mas é
fundamental para a nossa saúde emocional
e cognitiva sabiam que a fenilalanina é
a precursora de neurotransmissores super
importantes como a dopamina e a
norepinefrina Ou noradrenalina eles são
cruciais para nos manter emocionalmente
estáveis e com a cabeça funcionando a
todo vapor influenciando desde nosso
humor até Nossa motivação e atenção a
feni alanina também é essencial para
produção de tirosina que é outro
aminoácido que tem tudo a ver com
hormônios importantes como os da
tireoide que regula o nosso metabolismo
Além disso atua também na melanina que
dá cor à pele então a falta de fen
melanina pode dar sinais como eczema
pele seca mudanças na pigmentação da
pele como melasma e e sintomas de
hipotiroidismo podem estar relacionados
e do lado emocional e cognitivo a
deficiência de
fenilalanina pode diminuir o nosso
estado de alerta causar confusão mental
desorientação perda de memória em casos
mais graves até estar relacionada a
demência Sem falar que pode levar a
depressão Considerando o seu papel na
produção dos neurotransmissores que
regulam o humor pessoal o aminoácido
treonina é essencial não só pra saúde da
nossa pele do trato de digestório e do
sistema de defesa imune mas também paraa
manutenção das proteínas estruturais
como é o caso do colágeno elastina Então
essas proteínas são o segredo para
mantermos nossa Pele Saudável e elástica
e paraa reparação dos tecidos evitando
assim as famosas rugas então a treonina
tem um papel muito importante na
produção da musina aquela proteína que
faz parte do muco nosso sistema
gastrointestinal então o muco é
pra digestão atuando como uma barreira
que protege as paredes do trato
gastrointestinal dos os estomacais e
facilita também movimento dos alimentos
contribuindo para uma digestão e
evacuação
saudáveis além disso a tronina ajuda na
produção de anticorpos e na manutenção
do Timo aquele órgão onde as células T
de defesa do organismo nosso sangue
ficam e amadurecem então a falta de
treonina pode ser bem problem Ática pode
causar desde problemas digestórios como
diarreia constipação e digestão até
envelhecimento precoce da pele pode
também afetar nosso sistema nervoso
contribuindo para a degeneração da
medula espinhal e até mesmo estar ligado
à condições mais sérias como esclerose
múltipla devido ao seu papel na
manutenção das proteínas estruturais e
suporte ao sistema de defesa o sistema
imune e o conhecido triptofano vocês
sabiam que ele é um dos blocos de
construção das proteínas e um precursor
Vital da serotonina a serotonina que é
frequentemente chamado de hormônio do
bem-estar tem um papel enorme na
regulação do nosso humor sono e até na
digestão mas o triptofano ele também é
necessário pra produção de melatonina
que ajuda a regular nossos ciclos de
sono e vigília e também de niacina ou
vitamina B3 essencial pro nosso
metabolismo energético e saúde celular o
triptofano também é fundamental para o
bom funcionamento do nosso sistema
imunológico ajudando a regular a
Resposta imune e a inflamação agora
imagine o que acontece quando não temos
triptofano suficiente a insônia e outros
problemas de sono podem aparecer a falta
de triptofano pode levar a mudanças
significativas do humor como ansiedade
nervosismo irritabilidade e até depress
isso porque a serotonina que depende do
triptofano é super importante paraa
nossa saúde mental até o nosso apetite
pode mudar aumentando a vontade de comer
doces e também de carboidratos refinados
numa tentativa do corpo de compensar
baixa serotonina o nono aminoácido é a
valina ela tem um dos três Amino ela é
um dos três aminoácidos cadeia
ramificada junto com a leucina
isoleucina que são super importantes
para saúde muscular e para manter o
nosso metabolismo energético lá em cima
se você pratica muito atividade física
esses aminoácidos são os seus grandes
Aliados ajudando na recuperação muscular
na síntese de proteínas e na geração de
energia durante o exercício Além disso
ela tem um papel importante na nossa
capacidade cognitiva e na defesa do
sistema imune agora Se você começar a
sentir fraqueza geral especialmente
muscular isso pode ser um sinal de de
falta de valina Então essa fraqueza pode
afetar tanto suas atividades diárias
quanto a sua performance nos treinos aí
você pode ter como consequência atrofia
muscular tremores ou espaos musculares e
até falta de coordenação são sintomas
que podem apcer impactar diretamente na
sua qualidade de vida pessoal se você
está sentindo algum desses sintomas é
super importante conversar com o médico
para entender o que está contecendo e
para quem quer aumentar a ingestão
desses aminoácidos essenciais tem muita
opção boa por aí carnes como frango peru
carne bovina peixes ovos produtos láctos
e não vamos esquecer das leguminosas
como feijões lentilhas grão de bico além
de noses sementes e até produtos de soja
fermentada esses alimentos são ricos em
aminoácidos essenciais e podem ajudar a
manter a sua saúde em dia Então pessoal
vamos vamos prestar atenção no nosso
corpo na nossa alimentação Ok combinado
um grande abraço e um beijo no seu
coração você é Vera